julie casimir renard était contente son
cadeau non il m'a même fermé sa malone
et parce que je lui apportais des
caramels mous au café alors qu'il n'aime
que les chocolats au café fourré au
caramel ou tu sais il est vraiment
difficile et brognon léonard je sais
mais quand vous c'est mon ami après tout
tu as raison tiens je vais te donner ce
paquet là y'a dit il faut colin au café
fourré de caramels mous l'on n'est pas
content je lui porte tout de suite
d'accord a dit à
l'ats
bonjour mademoiselle plus uni c'est que
désirez-vous viens je voudrais je
voudrais qu'à un grand verre 2 je n'ai
pas d'alcool personnes l'an en bois dans
l'île aux enfants progressent
d'interdire à non pas du tout mais même
monsieur justin bel factor considère
qu'il ya beaucoup d'autres choses à
boire bien meilleur que de l'alcool et
puis après tout ils ont raison et bien
vous allez me donner un verre de rang
jacques delors en jade sage en effet
tenait au
passage dans l'île oui non je me
présente albert d'opinion et vous m'avez
fait une émotion j'ai cru que vous étiez
albert travelling c'est un imprésario
qui veut faire signer un contrat à
casimir pour le promener dans une cage à
travers le monde comme un horrible et
gros monde autres après je n'ai rien à
voir avec un personnage à bobino non je
ne suis qu'un modeste touristes amoureux
de votre père vous avez raison je savais
que une bénéficions d'un climat unique
il fait beau tous les jours comme dit la
chanson c'est le printemps tous les
jours mais ça nous rend un peu
insouciant
ou le rock est un peu parce que je me
dis que si par hasard il y avait un
ouragan ou une tempête de neige nous
serions complètement s'en défend c'est
donc pas de chasse neige pour déblayer
les routes pas de bois pas de pantalon
bien chaude revanche evren personnes en
passons
mais alors alors là non une tempête de
neige plus provoquerait une panique
générale je pense bien ce serait
horrible
tenez voilà pour le range à bhl missira
moiselle vous amuser
merci
[Applaudissements]
j'ai l'air bien étrange ce monsieur
[Musique]
ça y est léonard est content mais les
malades à la ddt et oui il a voulu
manger du chocolat au caramel danseuse
il est vraiment incorrigible léonard
mais que se passe-t-il à vous êtes bien
même ce jury monsieur kazimi c'est bien
il me plaît ce sont des enfants mineurs
sur le bateau les battures jim d'évacuer
toute la population de l'île aux enfants
bon mais je ne veux pas m'en aller moi
mais vous viendrez plus tard l utah cela
serial météo annoncent l'arrivée se
relisent d'une terrible tempête de neige
une tempête de neige l'épouvanté et il
m'a fait
part du genre à porter mais mais mais
jouait mehboubullah vous faites
exactement mais on a exactement ce que
je dis tout se passera bien maaseik
julie marchand de la
gemmi wii fait casimir l'heure est très
grave mais vous nommé chef de ce groupe
moi mais écolo en jeu faire eh bien
d'abord d'abord signé la déclaration des
chefs de groupements - attendez je vais
lire ça attentivement vous dépensez
parure la tempête de neige arrive la
balle tant défaut signé tout de suite un
bon bain d'accord avec toi je vais
signer voici ainsi les longues c'est le
chef de groupe merci mon brave bonjour
tout le monde bonjour facteur pas encore
sur le bateau avec les autres a tous
voila je comprends pas du tout je lis
mais personne n'a embarqué sur un bateau
non fait la tempête de neige qui
approche qu'est ce que vous racontez
mais il n'y a jamais eu de tempête de
neige il n'est pas prêt d'en avoir une
je viens justement de voir monsieur
cumulus avant que monsieur que croire
monsieur cumulus et alors la météo bah
elle avait pas plus de travail que les
autres jours ça c'est vrai tu travailles
par contre c'est moi qui en ait un parce
que j'ai pas mal de courriers
aujourd'hui justement casimir j'ai un
télégramme pour toi pour moi voilà merci
voyons cela
ça alors un télégramme
voyons casimir je viens d'apprendre
comme sur travelling parti pour te voir
dans nos enfants méfie-toi hawk
l'archivage
savent alors monsieur travailler oui oui
c'est bien moi albert travelling plus
grand après sarrio du monsieur du pignon
mais je comprends tout maintenant oui
monsieur travelling tout peut encore
s'arranger donnez moi vos moustaches
déjà sûre bien sûr c'est un grand
artiste mais tenez les voilà que voulez
vous en faire eh bien je vais vous les
faire manger j'ai bien compris alors
manger manger aux
abonnés
[Musique]